well you all know Supreme Court
confirmation hearings that produced some
of the most dramatic moments in Senate
history and could contain some lessons
for judge Cavanaugh joining us now from
New Orleans they discuss the theater the
confirmation process best-selling author
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo now
Raymond I know you spent the day
watching old SCOTUS confirmation
hearings of the past so which do you
think Kavanagh could most benefit from I
did indeed Laura and I'd pulled some
because as I looked at this to nominee I
mean this is a man as you've been
mentioning 13 years on the federal bench
but what many people forget he was part
of the whitewater investigation he wrote
the Starr report which had the articles
of impeachment or at least suggested
impeachment of President Clinton he then
worked with the Bush administration I
expect as an as I watched these hearings
it put me in mind of Ted Kennedy who in
1987 dredged up Robert Bork's past
history his political history working
for Richard Nixon here's what he's dead
the man who fired Archibald Cox does not
deserve to sit on the Supreme Court of
the United States Robert Bork's America
is a land of which women would be forced
into back-alley abortions blacks would
sit at segregated lunch counters rogue
police could break down citizens doors
and midnight raids and schoolchildren
could not be taught about evolution
writers and artists would be censored at
the whim of government Laura I think
we're going to hear that type of
language that dystopian nightmare will
be painted again the back-alley
abortions all that dark vision they're
going to try to paint Kavanagh with that
same brush now it worked in the case of
Judge Bork because he was very defensive
I mean we can't play all of the hearing
but he was very defensive and sharp and
didn't quite know how to knock back and
clear his name
I remember ethanol should be where I was
working at the White House when that
went down and and I love Judge Bork of
course but he didn't the charm factor
wasn't on display during those hearings
and he he kicked puppies to I'm a
surprised Kennedy didn't say that
Elena Kagan by the way let's remember
Kagan currently associate justice on the
court she
a very interesting way of dealing with
tough questions watch this exchange from
2010 Christmas Day bomber were you at on
Christmas Day I should ask exactly what
you mean by that I just asked you where
you're at on Christmas you know like all
Jews I was probably in a Chinese
restaurant she was hilarious I've gotta
say you remember that that hearing was
like stand-up comedy but you know Brent
Kavanagh should watch something there he
can take that light touch which we saw
some of tonight when I was announced he
has that warmth he needs to get in touch
with his inner Jerry Seinfeld and have a
good time but let me tell you the the
admissions that we heard tonight that he
was an altar boy his Jesuit training
that may come back to haunt him because
they're going to try to use the Catholic
thing against Cavanaugh now your boss
Thomas took Clarence Thomas had similar
problems in that they they brought I
mean they threw everything at Clarence
Thomas including the kitchen sink he
decided to respond with righteous
indignation this is another way to go
watch this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
American as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you never have truer
words been spoken by my former boss
Clarence Thomas brilliant jurist has had
an amazing career on the court the
ultimate ultimate revenge it's a life
tenure Raymond Arroyo thank you